[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone who's ready for 10
tips to get you can use today to get
rich cool so cross browser browser
extensions
I'm posh Matt claypot go by posh there
are hundred million Matt's I have been
at Mozilla where I've been a developer
advocate for three years but I've been
at Mozilla for eight years which in tech
years is one hundred thousand years you
may know me as the creator of does honey
badger care comm yeah I work for Mozilla
we are a non-profit who makes a product
you may have heard of called Firefox we
are committed to an independent and open
web and we've been doing that for quite
some time 20-some odd years if you
haven't used Firefox recently try it
there now I've done my job the rest of
this is just gravy cool so I am here
today to talk to you about cross browser
browser extensions so we're gonna start
with the eighth grade book the eighth
grade book report version of this which
is what is an extension an extension is
a bundle of code and data that modifies
or augments the functionality of a piece
of software that's so generic has to be
useless but we can compare and contrast
to other things to learn a little bit
more what's an extension versus what's a
plug-in a plug-in is a thing that
doesn't exist anymore but you may have
flash on your system which is sort of
the last remaining plug in plugins
provide sort of extra capabilities to a
browser but they act in a way that's
completely disjoint from the browser the
browser goes hey here's a rectangle on
the screen you can use that and we'll
leave you alone and they say great I'm
gonna overrun my buffers and compromise
your browser
and that's how plugins work so that's we
confused with extensions and extensions
versus add-ons for the longest time at
Mozilla we have sort of referred to
extensions as add-ons and we we use that
is this big catch-all term because we
also use the word themes which is in a
way it's the visual you know visually
change the browser or dictionaries or
language packs and all those things so
really when I if you ever hear you say
add-on instead of extension I kind of
usually just mean extension but
extensions are a subset of add-ons as
you can see from that subset symbol I
have read math ever so we're gonna start
with a brief history of extensions just
to tell you how we got to where we are
today
spoiler today we got to a pretty cool
place what is with all things with the
web I want you really to be excited for
eighteen months from now or two years
from now but I'm here to get people
already curious and excited about
extensions so they can start playing
with things as the ecosystem matures so
a brief history of extensions fun fact
not opera but Internet Explorer had
extensions first granted they were
ActiveX
plugins and they took a form of com
codes they're really C++ bundles that
you attach to IE but if you ever used
the computer with 12 toolbars those
extensions so really in 1999 IE 5
actually broke the ground here and said
we are going to allow extensibility in
the browser
turns out the browser is a pretty cool
thing we haven't decided to commit
antitrust yet but we're about to but so
first we're in the extend phase of
embrace extend extinguish and so
extensions were born not to be outdone
five years later the Mozilla project
which formed out of the ashes of
Netscape fun fact they're still Netscape
code in Firefox the good stuff that's
left behind all the bad stuff in replace
the Mozilla project had this big
monolithic suite that was a male browser
and a composer and all of these things
and some went in there was like what if
we just shipped a good web browser so
they took the Mozilla suite and they
took all the stuff that wasn't the
browser out and they made this thing
called Firefox and that came out in 2004
and in the Mozilla suite there was a
concept of extensions so in version 1 a
Firefox there is a concept of extensions
opera 5 years later after that in their
version 10 so this is opera in the
Presto era still they were using they
released a model for extensions right
behind them two years after their launch
google chrome camera on the chrome icon
was shiny I really like that I just I
mean it looks a little bit more GLaDOS
but it's also like IIIi missed I missed
the skeuomorphic icons they released
their extension model this is sort of
actually a really important moment in
extensions and you're gonna see why in a
little bit also in 2010 Safari had
actually released their own version of
extensions which is really not just
similar to Chrome's version and we're
gonna touch upon that again a bit more
later as well so first we're going to
talk about in detail Firefox extensions
and that's because I work for Mozilla
and that's literally my job is to talk
to you about Firefox extensions I also
think they've come the furthest apart
from perhaps sort of the IE two edge
transition Firefox extensions I think
have come probably the furthest from
what they were to what they are so
Firefox 1 it's fun fun fact to this day
news outlets just use this version box
logo which was drawn I think on a napkin
no offense to the original drawers but
you know it's it has a certain 2004 is
gonna say quad to it I registered
Firefox logo com so people can find the
good version anyway Firefox one had
extensions but how did they work they
use something called zoo
quick Shah has if you've ever heard of
Zul or use the Zul on purpose
hey ah the zoo was super cool right this
is 2004 XML is going to save the web XML
HTML xhtml is where we're going I picked
up my O'Reilly copy of the XSLT handbook
because that was where we were headed
everyone loved making a small mistake
and getting a yellow screen instead of a
webpage so we were so jazzed by that XML
is the future why not build not just the
web pages in XML but actually the entire
user interface of the browser in XML
which is actually true to this day we're
slowly working to fix that but on the
entire interface of Firefox actually
rendered by a web renderer that knows
how to use XML and XSLT and things like
that so the Firefox UI is actually a web
page sort of and then it uses that same
engine to render the web pages
themselves it's powered by zoo and zoo
stands for XML user interface language
so it's the extensible markup language
user interface language and this allows
you to define actually relatively
sophisticated kind of early web
component things they're super neat
there's a binding language you define
all this behavior and you can define
this behavior in C++ and JavaScript and
define a structure in XML and then apply
it to a page using CSS you say like the
behavior of this element in CSS is
defined by this cieth this C++ file
super wacky totally works but a little
little stale and so extensions worked
the same way when you wanted to extend
Firefox you provided a bundle of Zul and
that bundle of Zul was roughly
structured the same way the browser was
right if you wanted to change the the
skin of the browser you put some files
in a folder called skin it was looked a
lot but like most like the modding
community and in fact it was really just
a big stack of patches monkey patches so
you had the browser
and then an extension and then another
extension that may have been dimly aware
that the other extension exists maybe to
touch to different parts of the browser
and then another extension and this
diagram sort of shows what might happen
in that situation and the answer is
they're gonna stomp all over each other
right unless you know how to behave
unless you know how to cooperate
you're gonna redefine a method that
another was already redefined and maybe
you did an alias the most recent version
etc and you got a lot of griddle flaky
crashy
buggy extensions but we had extensions
and some sanctions actually and the only
two thousand were one of the defining
things about Firefox right ad blockers
and conte and you know user scripts and
grease monkey it was it was a really
really awesome time and people have
figured out how to tame these sort of
grody extensions that could do anything
but didn't really know how to behave so
we had phenomenal cosmic power it's not
I love Aladdin boat but unfortunately
it's whether you want it or not matter
how simple your extension was maybe your
extent should just turn the word cloud -
but right doesn't matter you still could
invoke all of the C++ powers of Firefox
and you know RM dash RF the entire user
hard drive because maybe maybe you were
executing the word but as opposed to
just replacing it so really kind of
dangerous and fortunately it was the
naive era of the late to Thor late early
2000s right and so we weren't exploiting
literally everything we possibly could
yet and we survived with this model for
a long time without severe security
problems safe fortunately in the year
2010 inspired by some of the other sdk
work that was coming out of other
browsers for building extensions that
sort of looked like JavaScript and
looked like something that web
developers could use we launched
originally called jetpack and then
became called the add-ons SDK and
originally launched in 2010 I mean any
of you familiar with that
okay cool wonwoo perfect um good news
I'm here to explain it so the SDK was
informed and influenced by everything
that had happened on the web since 2004
the explosion of Ajax event models all
this wonderful stuff as well as these
other extension models so it had an API
surface right we weren't just stomping
over everything you could actually have
a there's no specific endpoint from
messing with tabs and a specific
endpoint for you know maybe opening a
port to another process on your computer
and it was really well defined and then
it wasn't really updated right we're
like we did it we shipped an API and we
were really really slow to ship
incremental updates to the API that kept
up with the times this was what happens
when you have a labs team and then you
disband the labs team after have you
shipped which is sort of a shame not
it's I don't want to denigrate my
colleagues but we sort of in from the
position of 2018 can look back and go
like oh yeah okay we could have done
that better and so we had this wonderful
API surface which was miles ahead of
where we had been and then we had this
function called component utilities dot
import and this was phenomenal cosmic
power um this would let you pull in all
of the abilities that Zoo add-ons had
all of them so you have this nice little
componentized
API surface bundle that you could reason
about and then they can construct a call
to see you dot import and do anything
they wanted again which meant that we
didn't necessarily have to update the
api's because people could just pull in
the superpowers they needed as opposed
to getting the API however once again
phenomenal cosmic powers whether you
want them or not and whether you know
how to use them safely or not sort of
the discussion of safety and computer
programming is the thing we talk about
all the time now but back then it was
still sort of assumed that you would
just you know will just write safe code
we find meanwhile like I said chrome
headship its extension API
and Chrome extensions how many of you
for written or use a Chrome extension
yeah okay cool they are based on HTML
they use CSS and JavaScript web
technology so which is great because web
developers are probably the most common
implementers of extensions and the early
days it seemed like maybe browser makers
we're gonna be able to get extensions
and it was like oh no wait web
developers are the audience we're
looking for more importantly permissions
so you couldn't just invoke superpowers
when you wanted them if you wanted to be
able to capture the page at install time
you had to say I'm gonna use this
superpower that lets me take a picture
of the page and so maybe the users
prompted about that maybe they're not
but if later on someone compromises your
extension and wants to capture the page
if it's not a feature of the extension
it doesn't happen the API you do they're
not there or errors out and you are
protected from malicious behavior
because you sort of whitelist upfront
say here all the things that I'm going
to do if you've ever installed an
Android application you get that big
long list and you go sure sure whatever
and that's the same model right you it
does lead to people asking for
everything up front and that can be sort
of a messy situation where users start
properly informed of what they're
consenting to but compared to I have
this special plug that lets me do it
wherever I want way way better and so in
the year 2018
now with our updated logos chrome and
opera and brave and beaker and chromium
based browsers in general I'm gonna use
Chrome and opera as the representatives
of those are my apologies if your
favorite is not there were the
beneficiaries so 2015 we publish a blog
post called the feature of developing
Firefox add-ons member add-ons means
extensions in this situation and we were
implementing a new extension API called
web extensions largely compatible with
the model used by Chrome and opera to
make it easier to develop extensions
across multiple browsers so yeah
we decided that we were going to adopt
another browsers extension model how
many of you knew that Firefox uses
Chrome's extension model yeah cool so
this isn't once again doing my job must
be very satisfied here so now we have
extensions that can run in these two
places and here then we allow a couple
of the parties went to the w3c and said
hey what if there was an API surface for
extensions that was standardized the
same way there are api surfaces for the
web that are standardized and we sort of
haven't made a ton of progress here
however the browser extension community
group was founded with the goal of
creating a cross browser set of API for
building browser extensions sort of a
browser level version of web APs and
that edge came on the scene and they
were like Microsoft edge extensions
which are different from IE extensions
and they also adapted a model based on
this nebulous notion of these cross
browser browser extensions so now we
have extensions that work in these
places so that's where we are present
damn we have these extensions called
browser extensions or web extensions or
just extensions it's hard to say
maybe you just call them Chrome
extensions and they have this
architecture this is the most detailed
image in the entire slide deck but if
you can kind of see we've got a manifest
and that manifest says here's everything
I can do and then a big list of things
you can do you can spawn background
scripts and content scripts and browser
actions or to the buttons in your
toolbar and page actions which interact
with on the page you're looking at and
option pages which you know give you
preferences UI and then you can actually
manipulate web pages themselves and make
it resources they can access manifest
looks a little bit like this it's a JSON
file and it just lists if you've ever
seen a package JSON or an app manifest
use will look very very very familiar
we've gone to manifest version 2 it'll
probably be at version 2 forever
but you define a bunch of properties
about your extension sure name what it
does who you are and then you define all
of your capabilities right you say I
have a background page that lives here
in this file I request the following
permissions these permissions apply to
the following reg ex on URLs so you
could even say I don't want to activate
for you no evil com I want to activate
for my website dump is and then you have
the scripts themselves I'm gonna show
you the fancy es 6e version of this but
you can within a script actually invoke
these api's so this one's actually
looking for a user clicks the button on
the page or in the browser you know you
install extension to get those little
buttons that populate and then you want
to then you have too many of them you
drag them off those actions all can be
listened to and then you actually can
see if we're manipulating tabs right now
so I'm creating a tag gross example.org
and then which actually don't help
example.org is safe and registered I
know com is may fix that and then we can
actually go run scripts injecting them
into those tabs or we can load other
scripts from a well defined URL and load
them into those tabs or mess with that
tab or whatever right this one if
someone clicks the button I open a new
tab and I go extract the text content of
the first header on that page and
actually can extract it from the page
and bring it back to my extension which
goes you know I keep talking about
background pages and things like that
these extension API while awesome sort
of just predate the idea of workers
right now we have service workers and
page workers and shared workers and
audio worklets and paint worklets and
all these things and all that technology
and all that idea of a sort of Dom free
thread just postdates the creation of
these extension API so we uh we actually
had the concept of pages versus workers
and what that means is that when your
background script is running it's
actually running in the context of a web
page that isn't loaded in a tab
it's just sort of virtual webpage that
has a bunch of script tags in it the
advantage of this is you get access to
every single Dom API right so which is
very very valuable you know you have
access to fetch how you can assume that
if you can do it from a webpage you can
do it from an extension the downside is
it's a little clumsy err you have to
worry about the overhead of knowing you
know that you share this shared global
window object and things like that
so you know in a manifest you might see
something that looks like this where you
say polyfill background or you can
actually define just say hey you'll use
this page and a page effectively looks
like this it's a very very short stub a
lot of times you just see script tags
people omit everything else because I
don't actually care and you get these
scripts loaded
this doesn't look valuable at all
however you can immediately take
advantage of things that web pages can
do so in the intervening time we now
have es6 modules right and if you're
building a browser extension you know
what's gonna run in a browser and you
know which browser it's gonna run in so
maybe you can do something like this and
you can load a polyfill and you can load
a Dom library maybe jQuery maybe
something else and you can actually do
some computation on some Dom object
maybe you have template tags in there
and you're pulling on template
information and you can use es6 modules
right so this way you can say as opposed
to just loading a static background
script pretend it's a sweet no actually
do a script type module and now you have
access to es modules within extensions
and we're nice and modern and it's way
way more pleasant to use speaking of
modernity and pleasantness to use well
that's got way bigger than I anticipated
all right slides so happens when you
make a diagram like five minutes before
your presentation this is sort of a
lightweight architecture here the
background script acts for the
background page acts as the core of an
extension sure the manifest starts
everything up but if you need to
coordinate between you know a script
injected into a page and a dev tools
panel and the button on the page it may
be a panel that tips down out of that
and a side bar and an options page
because you want to use every single
feature at this exact same time you can
do that but you need to coordinate
via the background script and so there's
this notion of opening ports it's not
networking ports it's the same port that
a worker would have or an iframe has
right so you have a postmessage channel
and you can say hey i want to talk you
know I want to open a port from my
content script back to my background
process and I open a port from my dev
tools panel back to my background script
and I open a browser action port and all
these little ports all let you just do
message passing just like you would with
workers and you can coordinate and sort
of respond you can even do kind of a
redux a pattern where everyone's sending
their changes back to the background
page and the background page is the
source of truth and that maintains the
state of your extension it's it
ultimately makes a pretty nice
architecture so this slide I don't you
can see these two little lines at the
bottom of my one of those is my time and
one of those is my slides so you go to
the blue lines just advancing
interactively forward even as I waste
time explaining it to you and the other
slide is where I am in my slides but it
counts some slides which means that this
slide is my oh I'm moving away faster or
slower than I need to slide this is a
good tip so this is an exhaustive list
of every currently supported API I'm not
actually gonna read them out to you
or am I alarms bookmarks bar interaction
browser settings browser data clipboard
commands contents credential identities
cookies dev tools inspector window dev
tools Network dev tools panels DNS
downloads events extension extension
tights fine history I 18n identity idle
management menus notification zombie box
page action permissions PK pkcs 11
privacy proxy runtime search session
sidebar access storage tabs theme top
sites x - web navigation web requests
and windows
and now I'm ahead of time right feels
real good so um so you're saying to
yourself this is wonderful I can do all
these things and all browsers that
support extensions oh my gosh I did not
know this well not really though Chris
is really the current state of the world
also this is I realized right before my
talk that this is a lesson about how pot
is bad at Venn diagrams and should never
do them again because it looks like they
share nothing but really I meant to
label the circles so I'm never gonna
yeah this is the last Venn diagram
you'll ever see for me this green circle
is Firefox Firefox loves green this red
circle is chrome and opera and the blue
circle is edge and in reality you know
also the problem with real Venn diagrams
is the actual overlap here is ninety
percent right it's not zero percent they
share a lot of the same common core and
their extensions are there protection
capabilities that exist in one browser
and no others and two browsers and no
others etc however this may look a lot
like the web right if I pulled this up
and said here's what web pages can do
and pull it up this exact same slide
you'd say I agree and so in the words of
Steve Jobs what do you do about this
well we have a really sweet solution for
you feature detection
and that's that's the truth right the
the one the one bond we as browser
vendors make to you is if the keys there
you should be able to use it right if
it's not there it's it's not there um we
try not to throw a not implemented error
we try to make it say right if this API
exists in this namespace then you can
use it of course you know we're flawed
human beings you know pity us the wood
browser makers so here's where we are if
you use largely speaking the chrome dot
versions of extension api's everyone
because compatibility is the new class
toast will support it right so if you if
you say chrome dot edge and Firefox
would be like we don't you mean it's
cool it's cool it's fine not a problem
however we've also renamed that entire
namespace to browser dot you can see
that of course chrome has no idea what
we're talking about at the moment we're
still hanging out chat and see what's
going on and this spec actually defines
all of these api's to go from a call
back model to a promise based model
which is super rad
however only Firefox says this at the
moment edge initially closed the bud
that said they didn't support promises
as works as intended but they reopened
it because that just super super awesome
at responding to user feedback
obviously we're working all this out and
we'd love to even get Chrome's
extension model updated to support
promises so we can write pretty async
await and module II looking for things
however there is a polyfill called the
web extension polyfill and this will go
back and go into chrome and say hey all
those callback based extensions that are
on the chrome dot we're gonna polyfill
all those to be promise based on the
browser dot edge however we forgot to
say that right edge doesn't edge does
support chrome dot but when we detect
browser dot but we assume it's promises
and yet we're fixing it okay
so that's 100% of absolutely everything
that I have to say about extensions
there's absolutely nothing else to cover
[Applause]
so in 2010 version 5 of a safari
launched support for extensions and they
actually did a really really really good
job
what they didn't do was get a massive
market dominating market share that made
everyone use their model this is not
their fault the dissent that's anyone's
fault and Safari has a really cool
JavaScript CSS HTML extension API that's
based on the idea of pages versus
workers and really it's just but it's a
completely independent parallel
evolution so now we have something looks
like this but this is an API is this is
capabilities right if you want to mess
with tab as you can it just looks a
little different it looks completely
different but it's possible all right so
now it's Safari that self dot browser
window dot open tab versus the browser
tabs dot create but you can see that if
you took a look at this capability layer
and said oh we can speak we can read a
driver that speaks Safari and you
absolutely can that's a future looking
thing I'm describing to you and none of
you should be looking for today cool we
all cool but then we're all excited
about the future right the future is
amazing cool so today what are we doing
today
we're gonna start building extensions
every single one of us lock the doors
mozilla offers a tool called web - xed
which comes from when we called the API
web extensions it's a super nice
command-line tool lets you scaffold that
you lint lets you launch a browser and
do live coding when the distension OTO
reloads in the browser it's super fancy
chrome and edge and Firefox all support
what's called temporary or unpacked
extension loading where you say this
folder over here is an extension and as
long as you're a developer the browser
says I believe you and runs it and then
you can do live updating or go hit a
reload button and actually start
building these extensions and
experimenting with what works and what
doesn't and where the edge cases are or
if you've already built an extension
probably for Chrome you can port if you
have a router the extension that works
in chrome it will 99.9% work in Firefox
it will 68.4% work an edge but don't
want to do it is to try so well we have
a tool called extension test com it
takes a CRX file you don't even have to
give it this code just pack CRX file it
opens it up it runs a compatibility
suite against it just got ecstatically
analyzes for API usage and goes cool you
use the following for api's that don't
work in firefox but or hey this totally
works and you should just go submit it
to us where I wrote this tool it's
entirely on me if it doesn't work you
can come find me and I'm also working on
adding edge compatibility data so we'll
say yes it should definitely work in
Firefox and yes this should definitely
work an edge as opposed to just Firefox
so yeah today we can do you can do that
also you can complain I actually an you
enly mean this I'm a developer advocate
my job is not to market to you but to
listen to you if I come back and say my
talk went great I did not do my job but
if I came back and say I on the first
day of J's confer stage a has coffee in
the morning told everyone that I know
about extensions that you should
complain to me hmm
and then you all find me during this
week and talk to me about whether you've
tried to build an extension and it went
horribly wrong or what the heck were you
thinking or why is this also terrible
I'm gonna listen to you and I'm gonna
come back
and this all this stuff is actually in
flux right Firefox has a fully staffed
we're hiring engineering team working on
extensions extend extension api's we
think it's one of the ways that users
can take a browser and make it theirs
and have agency over the web and it's
super important to us that users be able
to do that because we believe that we
are a user agent and not a publisher or
government agent so you have to find me
and tell me what's terrible so I can
make it less terrible you want to find
me in person I am at Potch and that's
actually the end of the talk so you can
read there's a huge huge table on mdn
that has all the api compatibility
there's all these tools find me we
publish stuff on our hacks blog and
these slides will be available at that
URL thank you very much for your time
[Applause]